gayten and joe's character their dynamic
is something that people really really
like i was very conscious like stepping
into it and being engaged inside joe the
town of hawkins isn't exactly the safest
place to live in and some of that danger
carried into the real-life production of
stranger things these are the scenes
that were dangerous and difficult for
the actors to film
if you're little
and you're scared of stuff do not maybe
watch the season get watch it with an
adult number one
millie bobby brown had to do a lot of
spinning for this season 3 scene during
the scene when she is in the void with
billy her character falls backwards
after escaping billy's grip it seems
like a simple stunt but the behind the
scenes execution of this scene was
dizzying millie was hooked into a rig
that spun her around and around and
around after doing the same shot
multiple times and spinning over and
over again the nauseating experience
actually made millie throw up afterwards
and how can anyone blame her that looked
more intense than any theme park ride
number two
we'll get hot enough to 120 degrees we
just have to figure out how to get him
in here while the sauna scene in season
3 was meant to show billy burning up the
actual filming of the scene had everyone
on set dealing with the heat the
director of the episode sean levy stated
that there were 100 people present that
day on a small set that was very tight
and that he got over a hundred different
angles of the scene things got so
intense during filming that millie bobby
brown actually collapsed due to
exhaustion during the scene and that
shot is in the show finn wolfhard caught
her and had no idea what to do you can
actually see him looking off screen for
help in the final cut as he was
genuinely concerned for her safety their
commitment to the scene paid off as the
raw energies showed up on screen
number three
the finale of season three was an
emotional roller coaster and no scene
was more powerful than when eleven read
hopper's note to her to ensure they got
the best most raw reaction possible
millie made sure not to read the speech
beforehand she wanted to know absolutely
nothing about it she didn't even
rehearse the scene i just immediately
wanted to put a camera on me and find
the way i react and the way i reacted
was pure devastation and sadness so the
emotions were raw in that scene for sure
on top of this they also had to film the
farewell scene with everybody she said
they imagined it was the end of filming
forever and everyone started crying when
the cameras started rolling it sounds
like it was a very somber day on set
hey
[Music]
it's gonna be okay
number four
the final showdown of season 3 ended in
the star court mall and at one point saw
billy pinning down 11 as he was being
controlled by the mind flayer this was a
difficult scene to film both physically
and mentally millie bobby brown noted
the scene as one of the most difficult
because the two actors needed to figure
out how they were going to play the
scene with the level of intensity they
usually bring daker montgomery was
conscientious when it came to not
hurting millie during the scene but he
also wanted to bring his usual level of
intensity if you want to know how
dedicated these two actors are to their
craft they said they would run around
the mall screaming until they cried and
we both lost our voices because and we
don't even speak in the scene but we
were just screaming at each other sean
levy described the pair as two of our
most powerful actors
number five
daker montgomery and millie bobby
brown's intensity didn't stop at that
one scene they were bringing their
intense energy to every single scene
they filmed together even if there's no
screaming in a certain scene i'd scream
between takes and so would millie we'd
scream at each other until we cried
baker described the experience of
filming with millie as a significant
mental challenge and said that they both
gave 200 into every scene they did
together montgomery was screaming so
much throughout the course of filming
that he lost his voice nearly every day
it sounds like the dynamic between dagur
and millie was truly special
number six
let's keep rolling with dager
montgomery's extreme intensity on set
during the sonos scene in season 3 when
the kids trapped billy montgomery took
his intensity to a whole new level and
may have gone a little too far in the
scene his character billy is supposed to
taunt and yell at the kids through the
door that's what was shown in the final
cut but there was a much angrier take
montgomery actually headbutted the glass
window and did so with such force that
his head actually broke through the
glass the glass was thick and not
designed to break so it was a shocking
moment to say the least and the kids
reacted with horror it was a very
dangerous moment and it was physically
exhausting as well i put everything that
i had into it but luckily montgomery
wasn't hurt still he was hoping the take
would make the final cut imagine my
disappointment when that take wasn't
used
number 7
another scene another example of daker
montgomery's commitment to giving it 200
each and every take during the shower
scene in season 3 montgomery was so
physically and emotionally invested that
he didn't even realize he had covered
himself in scrapes and bruises he
learned later on in the day when he took
off his makeup and prosthetics to
discover the injuries one particularly
gross memory he recounted was peeling
the skin off the top of his toes
i said are you hurt
what's going on i heard screaming his
commitment to his character is truly
impressive
number eight
yet another emotionally taxing scene
took place in season two when eleven has
a confrontation with hopper and we went
through so many different emotions we
get angry at each other we are like we
are like father and daughter it also
sounded like the whole experience was
therapeutic for the actors as brown
stated that arguing wasn't limited to
just on camera we got angry with each
other and we would express our feelings
on and off the set david harbour also
had a cathartic experience filming these
emotionally demanding scenes it was a
sort of unlocking in me as a human being
of like a love that was uh human but
that was pure number nine
will's possession scene in season two
wasn't the most fun experience for noah
schnapp he had to wear black contacts
throughout the day of shooting which
burned his eyes and he was nervous to
have to perform the seizure part of the
scene it was really scary you kind of
just lock up and i had to prepare for
that a lot
on top of this it was actually pretty
cold on set the heaters you see didn't
actually work to heat up the room it was
winter during shooting and noah's
clothing was not optimal and the cherry
on top is that noah joined the ranks of
his co-stars as someone who lost their
voice due to screaming during a scene
number 10
when 11 closes the gate during the
season 2 finale there is a lot of
screaming and intensity it was a
difficult scene for millie bobby brown
to get through as it required her to be
lifted into the air on a crane while
yelling non-stop in between takes millie
would have to recompose herself because
the scene made her nauseous i'd have to
like take a breather throw up a little
then come back inside do it again
luckily for her the ever lovely david
harbour was right there by her side to
help out even offering her bracelets
that supposedly would help her nausea
number 11
entering the void isn't as easy as 11
makes it look millie bobby brown was
actually floating in a pool filled with
salt for this scene in season 1. it
actually seems pretty peaceful but it
was a different story on set it was
freezing cold the day they shot this and
millie had no help staying warm in that
pool the crew tried heating the pool but
it was to no avail as it was too shallow
to retain any of the heat fortunately
for them milly was a trooper braving the
cold to get the scene done
number 12
when 11 is in chicago with kali and her
gang kali puts the image of papa into
her mind and 11 is confronted by him
this was another very emotionally
draining scene for millie she got so
into it that even after cut was called
the emotions of the scene were still
running through her after filming was
done she went into the bathroom and
cried for about 45 minutes
number 13
a first kiss for anyone is nerve-racking
let alone having to do it in front of
cameras and an audience sadie sink and
caleb mclaughlin both had their first
kiss during the school dance scene at
the end of season 2. sadie was actually
told about the kissing scene the day
before it was going to happen as it was
never in the script the duffer brothers
revealed they were initially joking when
they told her but decided to do the kiss
for real when they saw how strongly
sadie reacted to make things a thousand
times worse there were a ton of people
watching just to guarantee maximum
awkwardness the first kiss was in front
of like two women
[Music]
number 14
sadie and caleb weren't the only two
that kissed that day right before they
did their kissing scene finn wolfhard
and millie bobby brown shared a kiss of
their own they had already kissed in
season 1 but that didn't stop this
moment from being very awkward as we
know the set was full of people watching
on top of this wolfhard stated that the
gym they were filming in was very hot to
make things even weirder all the extras
clapped after they kissed talk about
uncomfortable at least wolfhard warned
millie before going for the kiss
he was like okay i'm coming in number 15
as we've learned millie bobby brown has
done a lot of screaming during her time
playing the character 11. however season
3 was a particularly scream-filled
season for millie she stated that she
lost her voice five times over the eight
months she was filming but just because
filming was over didn't mean the
screaming was too millie was brought
back into the recording booth to record
additional lines and dub over the ones
she already did this meant screaming all
over again i was screaming so much
during the shoot
usually
but she doesn't like this voice
today we're checking out all the painful
scenes the stranger things cast had to
film from vomiting to slingshots in the
face this young cast was put through the
ringer it's been an experience of a
lifetime number one millie bobby brown
had a serious case of fomo millie found
season four to be the hardest one yet
for filming because she had such a dark
plot in contrast to her co-stars and
found she was separated from them a lot
it's a harder script it's a harder
storyline while that is pretty normal
for stranger things she could see flynn
and some of the others having fun on set
getting to do the more lighthearted
comedic work and she just didn't get to
be a part of it and when you grow up
with your co-stars and they're your best
friends that's rough milly said you get
to see 11 in the darkest state she's
ever been this has definitely been the
hardest season i've ever filmed there
have been some of the scariest scariest
things that i've ever seen as a human
number two well it wasn't its intended
purpose but it works to shoot the scenes
where steve is beat up joe kiri was
already feeling sick and had to have
menthol blown into his eyes to achieve
the desired redness which is fun to look
at and probably less fun to be
be in listen vic's vaporub contains
menthol and what is vixx for a stuffy
nose so we're pretty sure that's the
excuse they went with when joe
accidentally put it in his eye hey if it
was intentional maybe it helped clear
his sinuses number 6. let's just say
there's a reason schools don't allow
kids to have slingshots slingshots are
not toys they are weapons meant for
taking out the creepy upside-down
monsters and that's it well caleb
mclachlan clearly didn't get the memo
and hit himself in the face instead no
ah
number seven we imagine millie was
feeling that fomo around this time too
millie bobby brown split open her
kneecap before filming stranger things
season 3. so she couldn't do many stunts
or even too much strenuous movement
which included riding a bike and as we
know the cast happens to do that a lot
number 11. poor demogorgons deep down
they're just a guy in a seriously
uncomfortable situation the demogorgon
prosthetic outfit was tough for mark
seeger to navigate he had to do some
really difficult stunts in it but what
made it so problematic was his sight was
super restricted too it was so tough to
pull off that eventually they decided to
go with cgi instead it had to do things
a practical guy in a suit just can't do
number 14. we never really thought of
filming like groundhog day before but it
really is in some regards joe kiri found
the breakup scene he had to shoot with
natalya to be overwhelming as he hadn't
quite perfected the process of letting
go of his character once the camera
stopped rolling to be broken up with
again and again and again was
incredibly tough for him filming a world
of magic can be seriously tough in our
world from almost drowning to facing
their worst fears to some very nasty
injuries the harry potter actors endured
a whole lot of struggle so let's check
out which scenes were some of the most
difficult to film over the years
was
the most horrifying thing either of us
but before we dive in you should
probably subscribe to our new channel
the things animated to get all the
hidden secrets and unique theories
behind your favorite animated movies and
shows number one
well torture is never really supposed to
be fun so i couldn't stop crying even
when you're acting opposite someone as
incredible as hell and obama carter
being tortured in a scene is a real
challenge watson shared that it was
quite horrible to do the actress reacted
so intensely that she actually made the
bellatrix actress and director david
yates feel uncomfortable
number two
word of advice pass on any challenges
that involve being underwater everyone
knew filming this part of the triwizard
tournament would be a challenge
dan radcliffe did some solid training
time in the pool with professional
divers to prepare for filming but he was
definitely no expert meaning at times he
forgot what hand signals meant what
communication underwater has to be done
physically so when the dive team saw the
actor giving the help me signal they
freaked out worrying that dan was
drowning this this confused me luckily
the actor wasn't in danger meaning to
signal to everyone that he was actually
a-okay
however by the end of it all radcliffe
had spent 41 hours under very cold water
he was lucky the worst he wound up with
was just two ear infections
main thing that really sort of was a bit
frustrating
number three
the room of requirement couldn't be
everything for everyone all the time
unfortunately for bonnie wright this
room full of magic and power was really
tough to work in because of how
claustrophobic she was left feeling with
dumbledore's army being so big there was
always a crowd and being confined into
such a small space left right really
struggling her on-screen brothers
weren't such big fans of the room either
the phelps twins struggled with how much
heat the fireplace is throughout the
room emitted making for some seriously
sweaty actors and all those warm
sweaters
i've never told anyone this but i hated
that requirement set
number four
her character definitely wouldn't have
felt this way imelda staunton really is
a great actress we'd never have believed
that she actually felt awful when
torturing radcliffe the always evil
character was the furthest thing away
from who staunton was and the actress
admitted that filming those scenes was a
real struggle for her calling it
horrible and unpleasant of course
daunting was left feeling guilty for
days after the fact whenever she had to
go full evil you know the scene where
she gives him the detention was
uncomfortable for me
number five
this was a doozy
cedric losing his life is very sad but
it looks fairly simple technically the
truth is though pattinson suffered
during filming because of the stunt he
had to do for it the actor was set up
with some wires wrapped around his groin
area that would allow him to roll once
hit with the unforgivable curse let's
just say our pats was very happy when
the final cut was called
number six
even his co-stars were shocked he took
on a stunt this big radcliffe had proven
he could take on some stunts himself and
perform to the caliber needed safely so
by the time the goblet of fire came
around he wanted to amp it up signing on
to perform the big slide down the roof
of hogwarts for the cameras sure he
wasn't really on the roof of a castle
but the set that was created did leave
him with a 40-foot jump on wires and it
still looks pretty terrifying i will
never be allowed to do something like
that again number seven
when there are seven harry's things get
tricky we'd think that the fact that
radcliffe was the only one actually
acting out the scene when he played the
rest of his crew disguised as himself
would make things easier but it was
straight up tough and kind of endless it
took a whopping 95 takes to capture all
the action properly since radcliffe had
to act out the scene over and over again
playing each different part it was time
consuming but oh so worth it in the end
number eight
emma wasn't shy about how much she
detested this experience
yes i can tell you the worst right now
it was on movie number two we get
dropped by a dragon into the lake and
rupert wasn't so crazy about it either
considering he thought his heart stopped
beating from the cold it was the middle
of winter and the water they were in
wasn't heated and they couldn't wear any
extra layers since they had to change
out of their wet clothes so quickly
after out of the trio watson was the
only one to have the help of thermal
pants
number nine
ugh this part always makes us cry
sirius's untimely end remains one of the
top worst losses in the whole franchise
in part because of radcliff's
heart-wrenching performance this was the
scream so blood-curdling and guttural
that the team couldn't even include it
in the film it had helen obanum carter
and emma watson and bits so we can only
imagine how brutal it was for dan in the
moment especially since he'd lost such a
close family member around the same time
number 10
it sounds like a party but emma watson
wasn't a fan let's face it kissing
someone who's like a brother is tough
doing it twice well that's just not fair
to make it all worse when emma and dan
radcliffe got together to smooch the two
of them really got stripped down and
neither one was expecting it watson
shared that it was the weirdest thing
ever and they only told us about the
silver body paint the day before watson
has been nothing but honest about the
experience explaining that it was
awkward enough as it was without the
silver paint and the strapless bra but
whatever it looks good for the story as
for kissing rupert the actress was fully
clothed but it was still tremendously
tough to get through especially because
the two had such a hard time stinging
character emma expressed her frustration
saying it was supposed to be that
dramatic kiss but rupert and i continued
to laugh i was really worried that we'd
never get to get that scene because we
just couldn't take it seriously number
11.
animals are cute until you work with
them
if any of the actors were fans of
monkeys or bats before they definitely
weren't after filming with them the
monkeys couldn't keep calm and were
harder to wrangle than the young kids
and some got a bit explicit on set and
grind had a terrible time when filming
with the bats since one of them decided
to do its business on him
yeah that ain't cute
number 12
the spider is huge rupert grint was ron
weasley in almost every way including
the fact that they both suffered pretty
serious arachnophobia the chamber of
secrets was unquestionably the actor's
nightmare
aragog was portrayed by a giant creepy
animatronic puppet that looked real
enough to leave grinch shaking in his
boots he even called them the scariest
scenes to film even when they weren't
filming the presence of aragog on set
just gave rupert the creeps
number 13.
it definitely worked in this case
professor snape love him or hate him
alan rickman gave a stellar performance
and that was partially thanks to method
acting the actor kept in character
whenever he was filming on set so the
first scene he filmed with the kids
wound up being a real challenge for them
while rickman definitely didn't mean to
he intimidated some of the young actors
so much that they really struggled to
focus
we'd be nervous too luckily that quickly
went away once they spent some time
together off camera and they saw that
smile we all love
number 14
fans of the books remember him
the character didn't make it into the
movie but rick mayall had actually been
on set and gave a very memorable
performance
so why have we never seen it well the
actor did such a wonderful job that he
caused the young actors to giggle
endlessly and remember this was for the
very first movie so these kids giggling
too long could lead to serious delays in
production they tried filming with the
actors back to the kids and with him
across the room but he was just too
hilarious every time director
christopher columbus wound up not liking
the look in the end so he just cut the
character harsh
number 15
it's fun but complicated the high-flying
sport never existed before it was
written into harry potter so jk went on
to create a full detailed rulebook so
the production team could make sense of
what it was how to play and then film it
in a way that would captivate audiences
after all no one wants to be watching
these kids flying around on broomsticks
if we have no idea why harry was so
obsessed with finding that golden flying
ball aka the snitch their production
designer stuart craig was the one who
took on the daunting task of creating
what the pitch would look like and his
design worked like a charm in the later
films quidditch became some of the most
brutal scenes to film since those
broomsticks were not comfortable at all
even with the modifications made to try
and give the actors an actual seat to
sit on oh and we can't forget rupert
grint also got a quaffle to the face at
one point that's gotta hurt
number sixteen they loved it so much
they filmed it twice
okay well that wasn't the reason the
production team was forced to reshoot
the entire epilogue scene because the
first time around everything was way too
rushed and chaotic especially for such
an important moment all the actors felt
really bittersweet seeing each other
looking aged and knowing this would be
the final scene of the franchise
well we get teary eyed just thinking
about it
number 17
who left the food out for a team that
was usually thinking about everything
it's pretty surprising that no one would
have realized what would happen to the
real food they filmed with for days on
days under super hot lights the foul
smelling set made filming a total drag
for everyone who was close enough to
smell the stench and by the time they
got rid of it that smell was seeping out
of the great hall the actors may have
been chowing down on real food for the
first day but no one was taking any more
bites once their plates were filled with
rotten food a nasty sight for them a
tasty one for us
number 18
dan says it best
we work very much just like kids being
kids on a set filming the early movies
especially the very first one was an
absolute dream for the child actors but
for the adults involved well it could be
a bit of a nightmare since filming
anything with a big group was extremely
difficult with children who were
distracted by the magic of it all and
each other the big problem was like
throughout a take
our attention would like
would wane and come and go but it was
pretty sweet to see how much the little
ones enjoyed it where they were just so
happy to be in a harry potter film that
they couldn't contain their excitement
the wizarding world can be a dangerous
place so which of the harry potter
actors struggled through the most pain
whether it was because of sets or other
cast members these actors were left
bleeding bruised and battered all in the
name of art so let's see just how much
damage they endured hurry come on ow are
you right it might be freezing
number one it just hurts so good
poor dan radcliffe struggled through the
most painful first day on set that he
could have imagined that first day we
were trying to get dan's eyes to be
green because that's what they are in
the book sporting green contact lenses
that gave him a wildly painful allergic
reaction this was so brutal that he
couldn't even bear to wear them another
day we removed the contacts and he's
never had green eyes since which
explains why we never really got those
famous lily potter green eyes you have
your mama's eyes yeah absolutely and
unequivocally no
number two
this queen took him down rupert grint
didn't know what hit him
i'll be a knight
during the giant chess game the moment
ron was struck by the queen wound up
being way more painful than anyone
intended grint got nicked in the face by
a rogue rock and was left bleeding the
evidence of what happened even made the
final cut
don't forget we're still playing number
three like sun like father after seeing
this deleted scene we can without a
doubt see why draco is the way he is for
tom his on-screen father could be
intimidating working with jason was not
always a treat just immediately turned
into the most unfriendly horrible person
and tom even had the cuts to prove it
jason isaacs came into filming his first
scene with all the malfoy cruelty in
check smacking tom's hand on set not
realizing just how much damage those
fangs on the end of his stick could do
tom was left bleeding and with tears in
his eyes but
it's good for the scene number four snow
can do some serious damage the final cut
of prisoner of azkaban even shows us how
felton was feeling about those snowballs
when he visibly flinched before even
getting smacked
who was that a snowball fight can be fun
for one day but going at it over and
over and over again well that snow can
hurt
bloody hell harry
that was not funny number five rule
number one don't mess with hermione such
a good moment one of the all-time
greatest moments in the hp series is no
doubt when hermione delivers a knuckle
sandwich for the ages and while they did
it fairly safely on set the prep to do
so wasn't so smooth a film earlier tom
wanted to practice so they could get
comfortable with it but what he didn't
realize is that emma would have no
problem at all delivering a vicious slap
across his cheek quite frankly he's been
asking for it emma has admitted looking
back on it that she had no idea what she
was thinking never again did tom offer
himself to that kind of torture the
sting of that slap stayed with him
that felt good
not good
brilliant
number seven it wasn't just the actors
who suffered on this set director mike
newell really liked to get into the
action and wanted to make sure he could
get the best performances out of his
actors when it came time for the weasley
twins to fight newell wanted to see even
more fire instead of the prissy work he
described he was seeing but this
director learned his lesson saying of
course i was a tubby six-year-old gent
at that stage and i really shouldn't
have done it and why is that well
because when he got into it this
director wound up breaking two of his
ribs while demonstrating how to fight he
wasn't feeling like such a tough guy
after that one you know and you
shouldn't break a director's rib
number nine not the kind you're thinking
though
matthew lewis struggled through the
early years forced to look like nerdy
neville around all the kids growing up
why is it always me
and then he endured some seriously
painful torture after helena bonham
carter accidentally stabbed him in the
ear with her wand now this left louis in
agonizing pain nursing a perforated
eardrum he could hide his pain well
since no one actually knew until after
the fact when he confessed that he was
indeed suffering internal bleeding
number 10 good friends know when it's
time to put a friend in their place
hermione was ready to call harry out if
he ever crossed a line and this one well
he paid the price for
yeah that's not what she was wanting to
hear from dan that said her brutal
reaction left the actor with a sore face
afterwards
you're laughing because you hit me so
hard don't you okay
what can we say hermione is a
firecracker you don't want to mess with
number 11. this can't end well and
surprise surprise it didn't as if
radcliffe hadn't faced enough hardships
on these sets phil minks left him with a
brutal cut on his lip this wasn't just
any snake he was facing off with the
snake radcliffe was going to tet with
was the stunt coordinator on the film
who was wielding a pole with a boxing
glove stuck on the end of it and in one
take they got a bit too feisty radcliffe
shared that it went up and smacked me in
the mouth and my teeth were really hard
into my gum so i had a fat lip for about
a day number twelve you gotta do what
you gotta do and hermione was ready to
get to work even if harry was hesitant
but she needed that hair to make the
polyjuice potion yikes though watson
definitely did not mean to hurt dan in
the process only to help him but as
we've seen sometimes hermione just knows
what's best i
am still very much in touch with
everyone that i worked with number 14.
that's not quite the way you want to
leave a set
but unfortunately for dan bruises took
over his body the final film of the
franchise had stunts that dan described
as the greatest physical challenges he
faced off with vicious creatures but it
was scaling up chaotically piled
furniture in the room of requirement
while trying to find ravenclaw's diadem
that really threw him the fact that he
spent a full seven hours doing it meant
he was black and blue all over
by the end of the day i was just bruised
and battered
number fifteen it was the battle of a
lifetime
come on tom
let's finish this the way we started
and considering how it turned out well
it was a win for harry but dan paid the
painful price ray finds didn't hold back
and dan could feel it he explained i
wore padding but he missed it a couple
of times so anyone who doesn't like me
can come to the movie and see me getting
beaten up to be fair did we really think
voldemort would go down without a fight
but we did about three or four takes
and it was a really intense moment it
will forever go down in history as
probably the hardest
sequence i've ever had to film hollywood
may seem like a dream for many but a lot
of the times behind the glitz and glam
are actors struggling to even get
through a scene what the cast and crew
of tv series and movies have to go
through in order to get their work to
the big screen is absolutely
unimaginable from harsh filming
conditions strict diets that include
dehydration and life-changing stunts
you're about to be surprised at just how
many of the hardest movie scenes were
caught on camera
what was the hardest scene to shoot with
me
audio scenes
tom holland may have struggled with
keeping details of his marvel movies
under wraps but on set he has an entire
crew to help make sure the public
doesn't even catch a glimpse of what
they're filming however this can make
filming extremely difficult for the
actors when tom and zendaya filmed their
date scene and walked across the bridge
once the director called cut they'd have
to dash to hide in a tiny tent away from
the public eye and then we had to come
back out and then it got really late and
there was like a football game or
something
doing this over and over again had tom
and zendaya absolutely exhausted
bridgerton isn't what you would call an
action-packed show but filming the dance
scenes were brutal the cast weren't
professional dancers which meant they
endured six weeks of intense dance
practice but no amount of practice
prepared them for how challenging it was
to perform intricate steps and dialogue
at the same time
actress phoebe dinevor said it was quite
difficult to pull off you are a bridget
there is nothing you cannot do
celebrities may spend their down time
lounging in penthouses and luxury homes
but on the set of movies like the hunger
games they're splashing around sewers
seriously
it was a brutal three weeks for the
filming of the sewer sequence in
mockingjay part 2 they filmed in an
actual sewer that was painfully hot to
add to how gross it must have been after
a few hours liam hemsworth's very
absorbent costume weighed over 20 pounds
restricting his ability to even act out
the scene
very physically demanding very
emotionally demanding
getting to film in hungary might seem
like a dream but the shadow and bone
cast are admitting that while it was
beautiful a lot of the time it was rough
most of the weather conditions you see
going on in the show were a hundred
percent real especially the sleet and
thunderstorms now imagine having to
spend hours on end enduring these
conditions pretty uh pretty terrifying
actors danielle galligan and callahan
skogman said the cherry on top was
having to film in a cold water tank
during these conditions
cherry deals with much heavier content
than tom holland is used to filming for
marvel which made the whole process of
filming the movie difficult the war
scenes in particular are very
overwhelming and require so many pieces
to fit together needless to say tom was
challenged and said this role took me to
some of the darkest places i have ever
been emotionally physically anythingly
he even almost broke his nose while
filming
so i'm yeah i'm really really proud of
this movie
the after series is steamy but behind
the scenes we guess you can say the
steaminess evaporates we all know this
iconic like scene between tessa and
hardin right
well for actor hiro finds tiffin that
scene was suffocating literally he
wasn't able to touch the floor in the
lake which meant he was struggling to
keep afloat and not drown while also
trying to give his best performance you
think that's weird
[Music]
no
if they sound a little out of breath
during the scene it's because they were
in the end many toe cramps later they
managed to get it done
we've heard of actors having to go on
strict diets to get in shape for a film
but for this role in the witcher henry
cavill had to dehydrate himself
you heard us the actor essentially gave
up water for four days in order to film
shirtless scenes like this one in the
bathtub it's a very iconic moment
supposedly it helped him seem like he
had more muscle definition it got so bad
by the fourth day that he said he could
actually smell nearby water i was
surprised that
i still existed
just watching the battle of the bastards
in game of thrones was tense but for kit
harrington it was one of the most
challenging scenes he ever had to shoot
in his role as jon snow they had to
rehearse the scene for weeks because the
battle was one long continuous take
which means everything had to go
perfectly as you could imagine it took
hours and hours we're exhausted just
thinking about it it feels good to be
alive
sometimes it isn't wild set locations or
epic stunts that make things difficult
to film sometimes it's just baking we're
sorry to burst your bubble but to all
the boys lara jean is far from a good
baker in real life lana condor has
explained how difficult those baking
scenes were for her because she had no
experience in order to get through it
they had to hire a professional baker to
stand next to her and instruct her on
what to do and how to do it just so it
could pass as convincing on screen it
was a
educational experience you'd assume that
the hard scenes to film for brie larson
and captain marvel would be some intense
stunts but that couldn't be further from
the truth her most challenging scenes
were the ones she had to film with her
furry friend goose great team partner
gave a lot brie is highly allergic to
cats so you can just imagine how she
must have been filming on those days but
brie was able to find humor in the
situation it was kind of like the
ongoing joke that like i would do like
crazy wire work stunts but then the cat
showed up on set and i was like we need
to have a plan i'd be like stressed out
like washing my hands a million times
believe it or not the actual heist
scenes in money heist were a piece of
cake to film for the actors in
comparison to their season 3 adventure
on a boat they were filming in the
middle of an ocean in thailand in
weather that was excruciatingly hot the
mix of high waves and blazing sun had
the cast getting sick over the side of
the boat
actor miguel aeron even had a heat
stroke by the end of it
we won't even touch on how awkward
filming the fifty shades of grey films
must have been but we're going to
discuss what dakota johnson is claiming
as one of the toughest scenes to film
the elevator scene
the elevator was filled with the extras
we see in the final cut but behind the
cameras were 50 crew members all
confined to the tiny space where dakota
and jamie dornan got quite intimate it
is a kind of bizarre experience andrew
lincoln's first scene of the entire
walking dead series ended up being his
most difficult to film it's the moment
where rick is faced with having to take
down a little zombie girl that's when i
realized this is going to be the
greatest job of my career but also the
most painful this emotionally bothered
him so much that after a few takes he
was so distressed and physically needed
to stop talk about nauseating
just what did leonardo dicaprio have to
go through in order to finally win an
oscar well his time filming the revenant
wasn't pretty and it's difficult to pick
just one challenging thing he had to
endure on camera from having to eat raw
liver film with a real bear and develop
hypothermia we're going to say leo wins
for having the most difficult time on
set
i've never quite seen anything
cinematically like that watching saul
being kidnapped and forced to dig his
own grave was dark but behind the scenes
it was also grim not only for saul's
actor bob odenkirk but for jesse and
walt's actors brian cranston and aaron
paul as well it was absolutely freezing
on location and the winds were so strong
the dirt around them was blowing
straight into their faces check out what
walt had to say about the scene i'm
supposed to hold the gun out and i'm so
cold that i'm shaking and i'm like oh my
god that was probably the toughest scene
to do
he knew what he was talking about
charlize theron and zoe kravitz had a
lot to say about being on the set of mad
max including that filming the movie was
one of the hardest things they've ever
done
they were filming in conditions that
included extreme heat beating sun dust
storms and days that went way beyond
your average eight hour work day by the
end of filming the cast was exhausted
from the difficult action choreography
and dangerous car chases we don't blame
them
it was really fun please don't do this
to me euphoria is not an easy watch and
it's not an easy show to film either one
actor struggled to breathe on set while
another got so overwhelmed they needed
to leave the set completely and so did a
director we're covering 10 of the
toughest scenes to film from the
technical struggles to the emotional
hardships that the euphoria team dealt
with
i'm so scared
number one
the carnival shoe was tough for a whole
lot of reasons sam wanted it to feel
like it was one shot technically
levinson admitted it was a nightmare
six days of dusty and freezing cold
conditions made it rough for the actors
too zendaya struggled to breathe while
shooting needing an inhaler to get
through but considering what they ended
up with paying the price was worth it
zendaya said it best herself it was a
nightmare but it was also the best
number two
that's what happens when you improvise a
fight on set as in day i
it's not fun you know the vicious battle
between rue and leslie was tough for
everyone in the room that day both
actors fully committed leaving no stone
unturned it wasn't easy in the sense
that you know your mind knows it's not
real but your your body doesn't zendaya
wound up feeling so physically sick she
thought she'd vomit you have to go to
those points in order to
get to the beautiful parts even sam
levinson had to take a beat to step away
and recoup witnessing the horrifyingly
truthful performance
number three
tough to watch you can bet it was tough
to film the intimate intent sequence is
in part so successful because of sydney
sweeney's moving performance but the
actress really paid the price feeling
actual terror while filming alexa demi
didn't hold back with her banging on the
door which really set the tone for the
environment sweeney found herself in
no just a minute imagining the
circumstances was almost too easy in
this case
number four
can you say intense that's when it gets
it gets kind of icky feeling you know it
took about four full days of filming to
get just right and jokes between takes
became necessary to get through the
tough content when the actors had the
chance to check out the footage though
it all made it worth it what they
created was wild and they knew it
number five
while a lordy plays him tough as nails
the reality is he's kind of just like
this really frightened little boy in an
enormous aggressive body having to be so
nasty and cruel to alexa really bothered
the actor the co-stars have a wonderful
relationship in reality and while acting
together was a treat they did wish for
the chance to film some nicer stuff
number six
hunter schaefer's nerves were really
boiling over for this one
who are you
i'm jewels prepping to perform totally
overtook the actress and left her
feeling extremely overwhelmed before
even stepping on the set schaefer felt
the pressure knowing there would be so
many people there to witness the whole
thing we're talking around 200 extras
with that many eyes on you anyone would
struggle to perform
now this was an intense fight
choreographing all the moves just right
so neither actor got seriously injured
was a key part of the process
technically it was tough to hit every
single mark and then there was the glass
bottle to consider the actors had to
shoot the bottle smash six or seven
times to get just right and while there
were safety measures in place and camera
tricks to use allordy and cloud wanted
to make sure the action looked
believable meaning they couldn't go just
halfway jacob put on a brave face but no
doubt the hit being repeated so often
was rough it was tough to film but
fortunately neither performer wound up
seriously injured
number eight
sometimes you've just gotta take a
breather filming the intense moments
became really tough for storm read
the feelings were so overwhelming that
reed actually had to leave the set to
get herself together and breathe easy
for a bit while there was rough content
in the first season as well the actress
found it easier to shake off before
whereas this time around some of those
intense emotions from filming are still
with her
number nine
at one point during the second season a
whole new challenge presented itself for
zendaya filming certain tough scenes
became much more difficult part way
through because the actress didn't know
what exactly was coming next for rue
it's all pretty painful uh
because i care about her after going on
such a journey with her character it's
no surprise in day of feels so deeply
for her
number 10
filming a hit series is tough enough
filming during a pandemic is a whole
other feat the production team regrouped
and figured out a way complicated as it
was to safely film a couple of specials
between seasons it forced me to upend
the entire structure of the series the
self-contained chamber pieces with
zendaya and hunter shafer were an
emotional ride for the actors and a
logistical nightmare for the crew or
does not have it figured out luckily the
performers brought their best as they
usually do and the crew took all the
steps complicated as it was to make sure
everyone in the euphoria fam was safe
wow this is what i've been missing
twilight was a cringe fest for a lot of
the actors from awkward love scenes to
literal paper cuts in the eye and
freezing cold filming conditions it was
no walk in the park unless that park was
in forks washington we're looking at the
scenes that were just downright painful
to film
i spent so much time just infuriated
number one paper cuts our literal worst
fear well the twilight snow was made of
many things and one of those things
happened to be paper paper snow plus
golden vampire contacts equals pain
apparently and elizabeth reeser got tiny
bits of paper snow stuck under her
colored contacts her eyes were swollen
shut the next day ugh nightmare fuel
yeah i mean it was described to me as a
horror story number two a stake in the
foot should have been enough to take
vampire bella down while filming some
reshoots for the first hunt scene in
breaking dawn part 2 kristen stewart
managed to puncture her foot the reason
for the reshoots they all loved the
hunting scenes and she wanted to do a
good job of it stewart admitted we all
wanted more of it number three one
crooked thumbs up for this mistake
kristen stewart broke her thumb filming
her first scene as a vampire she'd
stated i'd been on the sidelines for so
long just itching so i was bursting to
do it which is probably why i broke my
thumb i was a little overzealous between
a hole in the foot and a broken thumb
it's starting to sound like vampires are
daintier than humans makes perfect sense
have you seen all those sparkles we were
able to really get close to every
well to most experiences that she has
number four pattinson has been very
vocal about twilight being a pain in the
butt to film robert pattinson had a much
less noticeable injury but it was
definitely noticeable to him the poor
guy injured his booty they were doing
the fight scene at the end of the first
movie and he nearly tore his glute they
had to get a physiotherapist to come in
and massage his butt cheek for the rest
of the day hopefully the physiotherapist
wasn't team edward
i think he'll be just fine
number five jackson rathbone experienced
the true wrath of the rib bone during
the filming of breaking dawn rathbone
did all of his stunts with a broken rib
i didn't even tell the production
company because i was afraid they were
gonna you know not let me do my own
stunts and i had to do it so number six
filming in the freezing cold rain is
fine for a werewolf but not so fine for
an actor for taylor lautner the scene
where bella first sees jacob after his
transformation was the worst of all he
said we're standing on that little hill
right behind jacob's house and it was 35
degrees and it was pouring rain on top
of us they filmed the scene all day as
soon as cut was called he and stewart
would run over to a heater and get
wrapped in blankets they'd get two
minutes and then they'd have to do it
all again lautner said i just had to
take myself to another world so during
the scene i wasn't sitting there
shivering it's challenging i like
challenges so i i like it number seven
honestly gnawing a hole in somebody's
stomach would be weird robert pattinson
laughed himself to tears over trying to
tear the vampire baby out of bella with
his teeth there was one shot where he
had to look directly into the camera and
he was crying with laughter he admitted
i was stopping tears from coming out of
my eyes and it looks like i'm crying in
the thing and i'm not supposed to be
able to cry as a vampire number eight
team jacob gains a point after this one
the last day of shooting the tent scene
kristen stewart had the stomach flu and
was vomiting between takes betcha
couldn't picture that happening in a
post-covid world huh stephanie meyer
admitted it was taylor lautner who was
taking the most care of kristin she
stated and taylor like he was over
digging around grabbing a garbage can
i'm like why is taylor taking the
garbage number nine taylor lautner was
sad over twilight ending the wedding
scene was his last scene and he'd said
that won't go away at all uh you know
it'll be more difficult he was
overwhelmed with emotion after it was
over taylor and kristen just looked at
each other not really having much to say
i'm looking forward to like that next
chapter in life number ten at least the
team considered a rig it's too bad it
didn't work taylor lautner had to carry
kristen stewart for an entire day down a
dirt path after the rig they designed to
do it just didn't look natural on screen
luckily taylor stepped in but he
definitely regretted it after a few
takes it was uncomfortable for me i mean
it's always uncomfortable number eleven
crying sweating injuries sounds like
being human is way more comfortable the
vampire intimate scenes were agony for
both stuart and pattinson pattinson was
a sweaty vampire which is technically
impossible and he was literally trying
to stop sweat from hitting kristen's
back i have absolutely no idea
how to do it number 12 rain rain go away
anna kendricks not happy taylor lautner
wasn't the only one suffering in the
rain kendrick joked that filming
twilight was like a hostage situation
because of how awful the weather was i
just remember being so cold and
miserable she just recalls her converse
being completely soaked through she
enjoyed working with the cast though it
was just that oregon weather that had
her struggling to stay enthusiastic so
they are trying to get back to to where
they were hopefully that's the plan it's
time to dissect all of the most
difficult umbrella academy scenes to
film including but not limited to
cornfield explosions amputations and
seven hours of blood curdling screams
definitely take some discipline take
some hard work number one the stars of
this show tend to put their vocal cords
through the ringer when filming intense
scenes in this example we're talking
about aidan gallagher who plays five
having to chop his literal arm off
five's arm needs to get cut off but he
needs to survive it so we had to figure
out a way of like him applying a
tourniquet with one hand aiden lost his
voice multiple times when filming this
scene and then again in post-production
while doing recording replacement
dialogue i blew my voice out quite a
couple of times shooting that and also
an adr number two you'd be surprised to
learn that one of the most difficult
things to shoot in season three was
running on a treadmill tom hopper who
plays luther had a less than great time
getting into character on those things
we look like we're old men on like we've
just broken our legs and we're just
getting back into rehab and to make
matters worse and actually when we had
to do these tighter shots we had to
pretend to run number three
this was by far one of the cast's least
favorite scenes to film it makes sense
why it would be shot at the very end
that was a very painful day we all had
to stare up into these bright lights and
scream for pretty much seven hours
straight some of the actors who didn't
have to do the scene expressed just how
grateful they were to be left out i have
to say i felt very fortunate that i was
dead yeah some of them also expressed
concern for their fellow co-stars
i was worried for a few of you a couple
times because like everyone would start
to go like blue in the face number four
sometimes the outfit you've gotta wear
to work can make or break your entire
day especially if the entire thing is
made out of leather and doesn't bend at
the joints the cast of umbrella academy
had a super difficult time performing in
these tight leather jumpsuits oh it was
so tight
no screaming
just leather not comfy didn't uh bend in
the knees or in the joints number five
okay obviously we loved watching this
dance-off play out but some of the less
coordinated cast had quite a difficult
time getting it down so who's the best
dancer on the crew
definitely not this guy
according to elliot the dance came a bit
more naturally for emmy raver lampman
and david castaneda but for him and the
rest of the crew rehearsal days were
much longer jake epstein shares how they
even studied kevin bacon's moves for a
little assistance they're like get get
kevin bacon get the screen
so we'd like watch him and then try to
imitate it number six who could forget
this iconic season two moment in the
third episode of the season we get to
see a great example of anya's powers as
an entire cornfield is blown to bits fun
fact all of that corn was grown
specifically for that scene the thing
that made it so difficult to shoot was
just how unpredictable growing crops can
be in an interview with slash films the
director steven sergic talks about how
stressed he was when visiting the
cornfields three weeks before shooting
and the corn had just barely started
growing i was sick he said i didn't
think it was going to be ready but
luckily farming specialists stepped in
and planted genetically manipulated
seeds three weeks later the corn was
much larger than they ever expected and
they had to re-light the entire scene
surgic told comic beets i was thinking
the corn is going to get up to three and
a half four feet like very tall grass no
we go there and it was eight and nine
feet it was insane it was so high that
it was dark inside when you walked
through the rows
number seven interestingly enough aidan
gallagher's most difficult scene was the
first scene he ever shot for the pilot
no not because of a wardrobe malfunction
or losing his voice a dozen times but
because he was so nervous when i jumped
forward and got stuck in the future
you know what i found no
nothing in an interview with looper
aiden discussed the scene where five
talks to vanya about the end of the
world as an actor the first day of any
production is the most stressful it's
the test to figure out and see if the
chemistry works between the characters
and you can feel out what direction
everybody is going in well in our
personal opinion we'd say the chemistry
is very apparent great job aiden number
eight we've got a lot going on in this
season two episode when five arrives in
the 1960s he sees his siblings fighting
soviet soldiers right before a massive
nuclear blast hits the streets this
scene was actually supposed to be shot
in one take but due to how dangerous it
ended up being they couldn't even film
it on the street there were a ton of
logistical issues while attempting to
bring this sequence to life in an
interview with before and afters everett
burrell the visual effects supervisor
explains we couldn't control the street
for four or five days or two weeks solid
to build and prep so instead we built a
360 degree blue screen on our back lot
in toronto we called it the blue screen
playground he also shared the sequence
was one of the hardest most complicated
things i've ever done
number nine
the action-packed and highly
entertaining fight scene between hazel
and cha-cha might look effortless
but it actually took months of training
i think they'll be surprised
uh to see us
doing hand-to-hand combat
and shooting guns cameron britain who
plays hazel shared in an interview with
inverse some fun facts about working
with mary j blige with mary we trained
for a couple of days before we went in
and shot it and she had been training at
six in the morning almost every day for
months she came ready to fight cameron
really took a liking to fight scenes
especially one in particular that he
says was the most difficult one to date
number 10 diego is definitely a force to
be reckoned with even for a seasoned
fighter like hazel in his interview with
inverse cameron gives us a bit of
insight into what it was like to film
that scene with david castaneda david is
so fast that my reactions are just
trying to keep up with him he explained
how he was essentially just there for
david to unload a barrage of punches
why are you here
well
diego stop number 11 at the end of
season 2
there is a major face-off with the
commission's agent on a farm but
something you may not know is that there
was a major setback due to the weather
conditions in his interview with before
and afters everett burrell shares some
insight on this snowy debacle half the
scene was shot out on normal grass out
in the field and then it snowed and it
never stopped snowing so for half the
scene we had to roto-half the actors out
and put in grass and then the other half
of the scene we had to do the opposite
we had to put snow in for the reverse
shots would you have ever guessed the
snow wasn't part of the plan number 12.
a fun fact we learned is that elliot
page learned to play the violin
specifically for the show in an
interview with pop buzz elliott shared
that he can play a slightly decent
twinkle twinkle little star but that's
about it he even had to have a teacher
on set who he says was very patient with
him apparently though even with
elliott's twinkle twinkle little star
knowledge he still had to have a
stand-in for the more complicated violin
scenes his stand-in was a 16-year-old
prodigy named imogen sloss
the umbrella academy will never stop
impressing us with complicated intense
and beautiful sequences it's clear how
much heart and hard work goes into
creating each season what were you most
surprised to find out about the show